Nos piden que factoricemos esta expresión que tengo aquí
4y cuadrada más 4y menos 15.
Lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta
es que tenemos un 4 al lado de la "y" cuadrada
y además el -15
no es divisible entre 4,
por lo tanto no podemos
factorizar de esta expresión un 4
y eso quiere decir que no hay forma
de quitar este 4
al lado de la "y" cuadrada,
por lo tanto se me ocurre
factorizar esto por agrupación
y recuerda que cuando pensábamos en
factorizar esto por agrupación,
nos fijábamos en el producto
de dos números
tales que el producto de estos dos números
sea 4 por -15
que por cierto, esto vale -60
y la suma de estos dos números
me tienen que dar este de aquí en medio,
"a" más "b" tiene que ser igual a 4
y bueno esto ya lo hemos visto en varios vídeos, necesitamos dos números que su multiplicación
me dé -60
y bueno si te das cuenta,
dos números multiplicados
que me den -60,
es más, dos números que multiplicados
me den algo negativo
tiene que ser uno positivo
y uno negativo,
entonces o "a" tiene que ser positivo
y entonces "b" tiene que ser negativo
o al revés
y por otro lado,
la suma de ambos tiene que ser igual a 4
esto quiere decir
que la resta de ambos
tiene que ser igual a 4,
o dicho de otra manera
que la diferencia
de sus valores absolutos
tiene que ser igual a 4.
Fíjate vamos a poner 2 números aquí
que no tienen nada que ver con esto,
2  números al azar,
me voy a tomar supongamos 3 y 2,
-2 por 3
esto me da -6,
date cuenta
que 1 positivo y 1 negativo
me dan de resultado algo negativo,
que es algo como lo que queremos aquí
y su suma me da
1 menos 2 más 3
me da 1 positivo
y si te das cuenta
lo que hice fue sumarlos,
pero al sumarlos me tomé realmente una diferencia,
la diferencia de los valores absolutos,
3 menos 2 es lo mismo que 1,
es decir, me tome la diferencia
de sus valores absolutos
y es justo a esto a lo que me refiero aquí
voy a buscar 2 números tales que
multiplicados me den -60
y que la diferencia de sus valores absolutos
me den 4.
Así que para esto pues voy a agarrar
y tomarme a todos los factores de 60,
y déjenme escribirlos por aquí,
todos los factores de 60
¿Quiénes son?
Bueno en quien
podemos descomponer al 60,
al 60 lo podemos descomponer en 1 y 60...
1 y 60, 1 me dan 60,
2 y 30
y...
es más déjenme borrarlo todo
y mejor lo voy a poner como columna
1 y 60,
2 y 30,
3 y...
3 y 20...
3 y 20,
después me queda
4 y 15
5 y 12 también
5 y 12
y por último 6 y 10,
y bueno ya sé que aquí se nota claramente,
que 6 y 10 es la respuesta,
sin embargo,
vamos a intentar probar con alguno de todos estos,
para que veas que solamente la única respuesta
es 6 y 10 y además,
que lo que queremos es justo estos dos números,
estos dos valores que tengo aquí,
porque fíjate,
si nosotros pensamos
en los 2 primeros valores que tenemos aquí
1 y 60,
si yo me tomo la diferencia de estos dos,
es más
supongamos que
1 es positivo y 60 negativo,
me darían de resultado pues -59...
-59...
entonces fíjate bien que la diferencia
o la distancia
entre estos dos números,
siempre va a ser 59
y es que el 1
puede ser positivo o negativo
y el 60 tendrá que ser
entonces negativo o positivo,
recuerda que los signos tienen que ser contrarios,
cuando me tomo
el positivo este es negativo,
cuando me tomo el negativo
éste tiene que ser positivo,
y si fuera al revés,
negativo y positivo,
me daría de resultado más 59
-1 más 60 es más 59,
pasa lo mismo con 2 y 30,
como puedo variar
los signos positivos y negativos,
el resultado no va a quedar menos más 28
o más -28
según como tenemos los signos,
porque al final
la distancia que hay entre 2 y 30 es 28,
sin embargo puedo hacer lo mismo
con todos estos
pero te das cuenta que la solución
ya la tenemos aquí,
la solución tiene que ser 6 y 10
porque 6 por 10 me dan 60,
y fíjate que si 10 es positivo
y el 6 es negativo
entonces cuando yo sumo estos dos,
me dan de respuesta 4 positivo,
y que es justo lo que queremos,
por lo tanto,
ya puedo yo romper,
esta expresión que tengo aquí
y empezar a escribirla
de una manera distinta.
4y lo voy a escribir
como -6y más 10y,
entonces déjame ponerlo aquí,
4y es lo mismo que
-6y más 10y
porque date cuenta
que es justo lo que queríamos,
-6y más 10y
me dan más 4y
y por otra parte,
tengo aquí 4y cuadrada y -15
y bueno,
vamos a factorizar por agrupación,
¿y cómo era esto? Me tomo los dos primeros términos
y de aquí voy a factorizar
todo lo que se pueda,
lo más posible,
me voy a tomar también
los otros dos términos,
y de aquí también voy a factorizar
todo lo que se pueda,
así que 4y cuadrada menos 6y,
pues estos dos tienen en común un 2y,
entonces 2y
es lo más que podemos sacar de aquí,
y me queda,
4y cuadrada entre 2y es 2y
y -6y entre 2y me da -3
muy bien,
ya tengo el primer paréntesis factorizado.
Ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo
con el segundo paréntesis,
tengo 10y menos15,
lo más que puedo factorizar es un 5
me queda 5 que multiplica a 2y menos 3
¿y qué crees?
2y menos 3 es ahora nuestro factor común,
por lo tanto,
lo podemos sacar de esta expresión
y me queda 2y menos 3
que a su vez multiplica a los otros dos,
¿a quién?
Bueno por una parte multiplica 2y
y por otra parte
multiplica a más 5,
y ya con esto encontré la factorización
por agrupación de esta expresión.
Realmente no estaba tan difícil.